hey guys I am just McDonald you're
watching games buddies and it's April
the 1st April Fool's it's actually
already the 2nd in Australia that's
right I lie to you every single day
let's see if I'm gonna do it again first
up some non April Fool's Day related
news you be are being pretty
tight-lipped over weather watchdogs is
gonna learn on Xbox one and ps4 in 1080p
which as we all remember is the most
important thing ever
creative director Johnathan Morin took
to Twitter to say that the resolution is
currently still being finalized wow that
sort of puts a pin in some of your plans
to launch scathing word stones at your
Microsoft or Sony enemies there have
been some uncomfirmed reports at the
moment these suggest that the ps4 will
hit 1080p while the Xbox one may run at
a slightly lower res but right now
that's just a rumour smaran commented on
the ps4 framerate being stable and
constant but did not comment on that of
the Xbox one whilst April Fool's Day is
the best day of the whole year for going
too far until friends you knocked
somebody up or need help burying a dead
body EA seem to have made Nintendo sad
the publisher made a bunch of tweets
which had a go at the Wii U being
underpowered the most racy or hilarious
of which came from the frostbite engine
account the engine can't run on the Wii
U so the tweet said things like
frostbite now runs on the Wii U since
it's the most powerful gentle platform
our renderer is now optimized for Mario
and Zelda the tweets have since been
deleted since EA realized they did a bad
thing and should feel bad going forward
you can expect that GameSpot will never
miss a beat when it comes to the tweets
of Gears of War creator Cliff Bleszinski
going forward we will be using the
hashtag cliff watch that's right we now
have dedicated staff covering any and
all thoughts industry musings and
potential breaking news stories from the
industry vet so you won't miss a thing
from Miley Cyrus always sounds like she
has a stuffed-up nose when she speaks to
is bird still the word for every time
the industry vet speculates on ruminates
or post something impulsively you can
rely on the fact that cliff watch will
be there to blow it up into what will
surely be a mildly six
new story that's for every
gaming-related April Fool's joke worth
knowing about here is a rundown of some
of the best google are hiring Pokemon
masters and you can actually catch
Pokemon using Google Maps origin are
offering a boxed service where you can
3d print your games at home Blizzard
releases mobile game happy Reba Call of
Duty have renamed their multiplayer
modes to things like Yolo and pew-pew
Kickstarter has dropped the e in their
name to reduce load time and bandwidth
while titanfall is getting Optimus Prime
DLC path of Exile is now offering pay to
win and Blizzard is naming the next
starcraft expansion herald of the stars
to keep the hots acronym consistent and
my producers gonna kill me from making
him edit all those quick cuts let me
know what your favorite April Fool's
joke was today whether it was one of
these or something in your own life
either in the comment section down below
or on my Twitter where I'm at just
MacDonnell that is it from me today but
I'll be back with more news tomorrow and
I promise I won't lie to you apart from
the date thing that's pretty much
definitely gonna happen the future is
great though although if you guys could
do something about the robots before
they enslave the human race that'd be
super handy okay bye